so that was uh
that was the introduction you all missed
because uh
those of you that missed the previous
lecture
um
thanks to young moss who did a great job
uh
motivating uh what i will speak about
and
motivating and also developing in a very
nice way
inspired by what happens in continuous
spaces
the notion of
richie curvature and discreet
so i will speak about uh
a different approach
by comparison it might seem
more pedestrian
but it's more discreet minded
because we're trying to do this in
discrete spaces
and
so it's a different point of view
um
unfortunately i will skip some of the
motivation uh
out of respect to
to the people that attended the first
lecture and to yanmaz but i will i'll
mention briefly
okay
thanks again thanks for inviting me and
for hosting me at the simons institute
um
what i wrote here as an exercise is
actually the first
little lemma or proposition
i proved after coming here during the
first workshop uh
in real analysis and computer science
with my former postdoc kevin costello
um
okay so
uh also i'm sorry i might sit down for
part of the lecture or most of the
lecture
as i'm recovering from some leg injury
um
okay so
uh
this is a confession slide saying that
uh
what we don't know is uh
as interesting or maybe more interesting
than what we do know so before i tell
you what we're able to do let me show
you a couple of problems that we would
like to but we're still struggling to do
so
okay you g is the graph
and
now
the main definition here is mtab which
is the t midpoint set okay so for t
equals one half it is the midpoint set
as in
take
so a and b are two subsets of vertices
and for every little a in capital a
little b in capital b
um you use the graph distance let's say
and look at
um
look at points along any shortest path
between little a and little b
and
by t midpoint we mean points that are
fraction t of the distance from a
and in the set mtab you take union over
all geodesics over all shortest paths
all
such midpoints
so that's mta is the definition of empty
to be clear so it needs to be
for every a in a and b it should be
precisely in this ratio no no no no no
no no no existing
yeah you take all the points that are
there
okay
okay
okay
and
okay you because this is uh on a graph
you might have a question saying okay
well what do i do if t is
sorry
yeah i didn't understand the answer to
the previous question there's a parole
on a and d it should be yeah the for all
but you have to understand it correctly
i have a lot of experience with the law
so it's not that this is true for all a
and b but you you look at all a and b
and you take all these points
this is what not just
okay
it's the princess
yeah
okay
right so just take uh i i'll be generous
so by team midpoint take the floor of
uh whatever you see here tdab
and also the ceiling
okay so if we had 2.5 take the thing
that's at distance 2 and distance 3. it
should only make our problem easier
because the question then
is
that of bounding the size of these
midpoints in terms of the sizes of a and
b
right okay so i let you
round up and down
to that and
so uh
seems like a natural question to ask but
i don't think has been studied
uh
you know in discrete literature as much
is a sort of brunkowski inequality
okay where so for now
uh forget about the e to the distance
square term
so the c
greater than or equal to zero here
actually is not a typo so i let you
choose c equals zero
to start with so you still have an
inequality that's saying is it true that
the size of the t midpoints is at least
so this i ask for discrete n-cube you
can ask for your favorite graph
and uh
and once again about the quantifiers yes
you want to show that for everything you
would like to
you would like to prove
okay you would like to show there exists
a constant
because i've given you dependence on c
over n here
for the discrete cube we would like to
show there exists an absolute constant c
so that for every a b subsets of
vertices of the cubes
would you be interested in this question
just for t
i hopefully i took the dependence out
with this t times 1 minus t so c should
be
yeah so
for example if t equals a half it turns
out c then you may not see the
dependence on of c on t but uh
it's a theorem by
jan olivier and cedric villani that for
t equals one half this is true with c
one over sixteen
so what we know is
if t equals one half this is true
and we don't know for other t
what was d square
oh yeah so
as usual the distance between two sets
which is defined as if they intersect
the distance is zero otherwise take
between the nearest point
okay so minimum overall little a
little what's the case
sorry what is the case of equality
uh
oh i
what
when is this exactly
i
actually it's a good question i
up okay this is tight uh but with the
constant i'm not sure
we know but if you take right you say
let's take a ball
um you know let's take a and b to be
antipodal points for example and take uh
take a ball
of uh radius one half n
then you get 10 choose n over 2 here
and you know the best thing is to take
the log of the whole thing so you see
that this is a linear term then
and
then um
and over here
there's a c over n and d square is gives
it's going to give you n square so you
get linear in n as well
so it is tight but
um
yeah characterization of equality even
for t equals one half i'm not sure
but that's a good guess yeah this
fragility to intersection between the
sets seems a little unnatural
this fragility to having the sets
intersect seems
yes so actually what they prove is
something stronger
um
this is replaced by and this uh now i
should watch how i call it this is
replaced by you could take uniform or
whatever measure on a and b
support with support on a and b
and take
contour of its western stein
distance between those two measures uh
w1 the w1
so
it's going back to remark from another
at the end of the earlier lecture when
w
sergey said according to varshik
it should be referred to as counter of
its distance rather than
russell stein
actually the first time i encountered
this
i saw it as crop krob
metric crop metric and that's for
kantarovich rubinstein ornstein
wasserstein where vasu stand is written
with the v
so this is this is some other i don't
know if that makes anybody happy
um
again this is just saying yes this is a
bit fragile but actually you could
replace it by
something like
which is what they prove
okay and the second almost the second
natural second favorite graph
of uh many discrete people is uh
the symmetric group with
you pick whether you want hamming
distance or transposition distance right
so what is the hamming distance
um well so you
look at the permutations and hamming
distance as in
you know just number of coordinates oh
you're right
one two yeah
permutations of n symbols and just
coordinate wise
i mean they're within a factor of two
of each other so it's that's why i say
it's you know it doesn't matter which
one you want to choose
and then one can ask the same question
so here we know less
here what we know is
with c equals 0
we can show for t equals one half
so as in simple burn minkowski but just
for t equals one half
so those are two open questions
you don't care for the rest of the
target work on your favorite candidate
said that health
sets a and b
for which
this should be optimal
uh
yeah this is a more tricky question
because even so
to this
these inequalities as jan mentioned
are
strong enough are so strong that they
imply lots of you know modified log
sublime concentration and so on so
even for the concentration depends on
the parameters t i don't think we know
the extremal sense yes so
i don't know
yeah do people think that
i i think yeah i think we're uh
you know your guests may be better than
my guest um
but i don't think
it's better than your guests
say the identity permutation yes
um
i think we don't know even qualitatively
what
whether the such a result is true and so
we haven't
yeah dared ask that question but maybe
you want to start there yeah
i don't know
okay so
was that just a question about integer
parts and pesky things like that yeah
yeah so i mentioned uh now i can see who
came in earlier
later
um
so for the midpoint team midpoint said i
said we'll be generous you can take both
the rounded up and down and put them
both in there yeah
and in fact for the
for so what i mentioned was for the
first result um
i'll show what olivia and villain
approve but this one for t equals
one-half is a theorem
and
they they do include both the floor and
ceiling
in the definition
okay
so let's see did i skip something here
no
so there's i am
less
uh
complete compared to jan max who gave uh
all complete references to the people
that we mentioned which is excellent i
apologize for that but uh you know if
you were in his talk you saw most of
these names maybe not playing on but
most of these names and uh the the one
that uh jan talked about was based on
you know these two um but he also
mentioned uh approaches by
storm etc so
uh just to summarize
maybe a way to look at the previous talk
and the development versus what i will
talk about is he mentioned a result of
jko jordan kindler and otto and he said
you know they cannot prove something
like that in the discrete context in
discrete spaces
and uh so our one way to look at our
work is that this result of olivia
villani and for the discrete cube and
say okay can we try to prove first of
all for all t some result like that on
the discrete cube and then more
generally can we just
prove something like that can we
formulate and prove something like that
for
graphs
okay so it's it's a point of departure
that's different and then
our development is quite different
so as i said here here is with the
constant c1 over 16 this is the result
of
olivier villani
and the second one shows in fact as i
indicated with the w1
okay so this this is
so there's a definition that will come
up in a second but w1 is some in
computer science sometimes it's known as
the earth mover distance so you have two
measures
uh this is the l1
um
uh
you know this is this is really
controversial uh distance between
measures mu zero and u1 where there's
some underlying distance here it's the
graph distance but in any matrix space
and you take
uh the best coupling
joint distribution between you 0 and u1
and the cost is
the linear cost sum overall pairs
distance between x and y
and
say gamma x y which is the
which is the mass the joint distribution
with marginal c 0 and u 1
that assigns to a p x 1
ok so
and this is the usual relative entropy
so mu can be any measure on
actually they restrict to uniform
measure on on the discrete cube but uh
mu 0 and u 1
can be anything and then the theorem is
that
new zero new one uh induced new one-half
so new one-half is
now on the midpoint set that i defined
um
for you look at the support of new zero
new one and then look at midpoints
for this if the support is a and b
uh
midpoints as i defined and then u1 half
is
is uh is a measure on the midpoint set
okay the relative entropy of this
satisfies that property
and so this this is what dion mars
talked about so he introduced a certain
w-2
and a certain interpolation
based on this [ __ ] plant type equation
and
so i'm going to skip over that
and get to what we do
okay so this is since
okay
and also i believe a student of michelle
ledoux i developed something uh
like what i'm going to talk about
okay so one thing is we we look at
different costs so w1 but we look at a
different cost different notion of a w-2
that
is now
due to catalin martin
okay so and then from that we can derive
statements for w1
so again as i said our motivation is can
one prove a theorem like uh can one
develop an interpolation between given
measures mu zero and u1
and prove a theorem like olivia delany
for stage can we formulate it first of
all and then
ask for what is
potential
what is potentially the role that
we saw
c over n 1 over 16 n in their theorem is
for general graphs
okay so w1 squared so i'll introduce
this tilde w2 tilde in a little bit but
it's uh
it's it's something that kathleen martin
introduced in
proving
generalizations of telegram's results
and so on
okay so here is the theorem but uh but
you won't
it won't
be completely
defined yet because i have to tell you
what mu t pi is
so there are two statements here turns
out so the second one implies the first
one because this this w two tilde due to
martial
satisfies an inequality relating to w1
that that gives one
um
so i'll explain so in the next few
minutes my aim is to explain the terms
that you see in here namely
uh w to tilde but also what i mean by nu
t pi what is the interpolation that we
do i have to explain
and but the point is that we're able to
derive a result like olivier will need
for all t between zero and one so we
introduce an appropriate interpolation
that does
but one thing i will already confess and
tell you is
mu t is not going to have support just
on the midpoints at m sub t
okay it's going to look at all geodesics
between a and b
and then
we will introduce uh an appropriate
binomial distribution with parameter t
and the number of tosses depends on the
distance between points in a and b
and
and i'll and pi is going to be a joint
distribution with marginal's
new zero new one
okay
so our one contribution is that okay one
can define a discrete interpolation as
in interpolation between vibration on a
graph
so that
a result of this type is true
on the discrete cube
okay so i wrote down explicitly so this
might look funny i'll explain where it
comes from
so
pi already mentioned so beauty pi
it has this explicit form where
so
so if you're interested in what this
assigns to some point z
what you're doing is
so delta z refers to the fact that z has
to be on a geodesic between you know the
sets a and b i referred to earlier
and then it has these binomials but i'll
explain more more carefully
just a kind of orientation question
this entropy function here is sort of
negated in the same sense it was in the
previous talk
uh or is this what we usually yeah so
this is the this is the relative entropy
so in this discrete case this is just
summation over x let me call this mu x
nu x log nu over mu
so oh so this is positive so this is the
usual yeah yeah solution this is
non-negative
this is the same as before
yes i think mu to be the uniform is it
gonna be simple or is this it has the
same difficulty to
oh similar difficulty yeah you can
assume you as uniform
and it's
basically what what's not difficult to
do is if you have a two-point space or
any complete graph
you know you can write down explicitly
what this uh the quantity on the left is
and take the second derivative
and can derive a boom and cos g type you
know you show convexity of an
appropriate functional
we can do that and the second thing we
we can do is tensorization
and that's basically how we get from
zero one to the n
this is a discrete cube because it's a
product of
n edges which is a complete graph
but if you give me something like the
symmetric cube i'm intro symmetric group
i'm in trouble
but defining it you know
is not difficult so there's a little
footnote here this this is just saying
that of course i haven't shown you what
w2 tilde is but it satisfies you know by
question schwarz some inequality between
the in a more well-known w1
um and that's how you get one
okay so let me move on to
so janma showed uh in in maybe partly in
response to uh sergio's question okay
why should one care for this sort of
displacement convexity of entropy type
inequality
one answer is uh that
at some point i'll show you a chain of
implications it gives you
you know
all the way from practice
enhanced broon minkowski and uh but also
telegraphs transport uh
entropy
inequality and and then consequences of
that for concentration of measure and so
on um so but you may say well those we
know how how to prove already anyway so
what is new that's this is telling me
and i think that's a legitimate question
um but
when you try to do in discrete spaces
what seems interesting is it raises
various questions that are completely
natural in the discrete space without
this other motivation of displacement
complexity as i try to indicate with my
slide one
and it showed more of my ignorance in
terms of what we don't know but i think
these are
very interesting questions
and
one of the simplest things you try to
ask or compute once you introduce
something in on graphs is
what is it on two point space does it
tensorize and what is it on a path
besides complete graph
and uh so the path
is the one that gives to what i wrote
here as an exercise um so even this i
don't think
is well known
um
so you can ask
the kind of bronchosconic quality i'm
asking for if you have a path or a
discrete circle right cycle
of length n
and
my guess is these are known and derived
using the classical runemankovsky on the
real line
or you know
yes
but
and uh you know a couple of weeks over
at the
aim in palo alto american institute of
math you know with group of us
particularly the guys so far i haven't
mentioned my co-authors and
the two here
uh sergey student james melbourne and
then uh my postdoc at georgia tech will
perkins
we managed to show at least on z that
using ron minkowski on the real line in
fact you can
derive on the integers but again this is
probably
you know sergey gave us some references
going back to the 50s
where they might have known that
um
well
we don't know in the discrete case i
mean the classical ones the continuous
case they tensorize so for example on v2
i don't know how to prove
something like this
okay so okay what is this xsi
so you know take uh
subset two subsets of integers and a
plus b is is as in the usual sum set
inequalities
in additive combinatorics which is i
guess you'll see more in the third
workshop
um
you know you take all pairs of sums
and
uh
so m half
the a plus b is this the midpoint said i
let you round down and up okay both
and so the natural question is can we
prove this
so
and this you
this i know is true yeah
i have given exercises in classes which
i didn't know how to solve but this is
not one of them um
actually this
so as i said for general t you can prove
this using bruno minkowski on r
okay for general t
but
the what makes it exercise and it's more
combinatorial is
turns out you can actually prove this
using the classical sunset inequality
that says the cardinality of a plus b
is always at least size of a plus size
of b
minus one
which
as we as
most people here probably know
is uh tight for arithmetic progressions
when a equals b let's say or a and b are
arithmetic progressions with the same
common difference
this is tight and you can use this
and if you want one more hint
besides this the am gm is the other hand
but my point of
throwing this on the side is that
whatever your motivation
original motivation might be this seems
to raise questions that might even be
interesting
particularly for
t between zero and one not necessarily
one half from some certain equalities
point of view for discrete and common
products people
okay so there is some standard
motivation for
how you can derive other inequalities
starting from this so-called
displacement
oh by the way if i don't know if
jan
said it uh or whether he even used the
term displacement convex differential i
think he did
but
in case you haven't seen that i hope the
name or the phrase is clear so then yes
without the additional distance square
term you're talking about minkowski
which is in a statement of
some sort of convexity and the
displacement connects to tom i believe
makan or somebody introduced me
is uh
is for the fact that you can do better
than bruno mancoski you're able to get a
better inequality
you know assuming the curvature is
positive assuming this kappa in the
answer
rotation
c over i in my previous inequalities is
positive you're able to do better and
that's the displacement part
okay so um
so there was a question in the previous
talk so i got put in this uh
for completeness so
by geodesic because we're i mean in
graphs we are familiar with geodesics
but
the geodesic we'll be talking about is
on the measure space
right so on w1 or w2 and so on so the
interpolation that we will we introduce
turns out to be we can show is a
geodesic is a w1 geodesic
okay in this in this sense
that if i look at
w1 so i will introduce the interpolation
nu t pi or nu t so the w1
of mu s
nu t
right in the w one sense is going to be
equal to t minus s times w one of mu
zero nu one
okay
so that's the property
so again this
i've already said
uh without showing a formal definition
but
so
and jan pointed out that you know
you you cannot expect the usual
you cannot expect telegram type
inequality with the usual or natural way
of defining w2 because um
already on a two point sorry
because there are no because there are
no geodesics and i already on two point
space you're in trouble and that's why
we're
trying to find other
other paths
so he this is basically how we build our
interpolation
no
yeah
well
i don't know
at some level in some sense yes because
we're only able to do limited things
yeah
yes i
it's a good point because as you so i'm
about to say what the interpolation is
okay let me say that and then i can i
can come back to that point
so first imagine you have uh you know
just theta one through
n
and then uh
here is a
here is
a simple interpolation
and in this we can use
on a general graph okay so
imagine you have a dirac mass at 0 and
then you know also at n
and now you take the usual just
binomial distribution
okay
and so how does that give us our
interpolation
yeah so let me put the
slide up but it
may look a little bit complicated let me
say
in words what we do
so first for
dirac mass between two points let's say
x and y
take a random
geodesic so random shortest path
okay
and once you have a shortest path
you do the previous you do the binomial
distribution
where binomial with what's the number of
tosses it's the distance okay which is
some integer positive
parameter parameter t for probability
and the distance for the other parameter
okay
this is if you have two data
now what is new t pi
so given you zero and u1
take any okay if you want optimal
coupling
but for any joint distribution pi
whose marginal server is 0 and u1
you simply extend it
you know by writing it as
as a sum over
dirac mass
okay
so let me give an example and here
there's a proposition by the proposition
so nu t pi can be defined the way i just
i just said
but it's more useful
if you know pi is optimal
you can take any joint distribution of
new zero new one but if it's
optimal in the sense you know
if
the joint distribution is the one that
gives you
equality in w1 of music
right w 1 is defined over best overall
coupling
okay
otherwise it's you know maybe sudo j
does it
so here are
two simple examples just to write it
down explicitly i mean on a complete
graph you know all the distances are
either zero or one
so you just you're either
so when is it one minus t
here's another way to think about
walking along the jade essay so t tells
you how many
sorry
t is the binomial parameter
so
the number of heads tells you how far
you've moved going from x to y
so if
in the complete graph case you only have
zero or one right because it's distance
one so if you are unsuccessful with
probability one minus t you stay at x if
you're successful you go to one
for all other ones would be zero
yeah so complete graph it doesn't depend
on the coupling at all
okay it's just this simple linear
and you can do the computation for the n
cube right following the recipe
so you see these factors because what
you have to figure out because now i'll
address almost question so we don't take
a single geodesic
then becomes a question of you know what
is a smart way to choose on the discrete
cube
does it help to take the
lexicographically first you know
the one that says go from left to right
and see which are the ones you need to
fix going from next to
so we haven't developed that approach
taking a a single path and then taking a
binomial or some distribution
for the tensorization
so we have something that justifies uh
or two comments on this binomial first
of all this is this idea is due to uh
johnson due to uh fold johnson in his
paper on
you know entropic central limited
central limit theorem for poisson
distribution
so that's that's where this is from and
for
tensorization to work you know we can
show that binomial is
is forced upon you
but what we haven't done is rather than
taking all geodesics between
a and b
the supports of museum event what
happens if you just take somehow one
canonical one
there we go
and that that
might
force us to think more about somehow a
unique geodesic aspect yeah
okay so we can write down explicitly
this is something like this is what we
get
right again this is just to illustrate
that for dirac mass you get something
like this but then now you have a joint
distribution pi with mu zero and u1
as the marginal so nu t pi would be
summing over all x y with that
okay
so the definition of mu t pi
more or less clear
and you know more generally you can
write it down explicitly
what it is
but
what you get is of course for any z if
you if you say you know what's the mass
on z then it depends on number of
shortest paths between
x and y or x 0 x 1 that uz
compared to total number of datasets
okay so that's the ratio
okay
so
the other one in my theorem so most
basically i'm spending most of the time
trying to explain very slowly in our
theorem which is
which is
which is already some non-trivial thing
okay so this this is the the one that's
due to kathleen martin i said that
that we use
um
again you know one one could just work
with w1 but the whole as jan tried to
indicate the whole point is to somehow
come up with the notion of w2 in
discrete spaces that
with the hope that that's stronger than
the usual w1
so
you know this
for graphs you can just think of these
integrals of summations and the joint
distribution
between user and u1 this is not
symmetric unless unlike w1 okay so this
is new one with respect to new zero
and similarly you consider
t2 of new zero with respect to mu one
and take the sum of the two
okay that's that's something what we
call w two square
so it turns out depending on where you
put the square
you get three
sort of distances here
the strongest one you know as you can
expect by khushi schwartz is when you
put the square on
d
okay if you put the square here
then you get square of the usual w2
if you put the square all the way
outside then you get w1 square
and this is this is in between
and that that
song used and then
one of my collaborators paul mary samson
also worked with it
he has some papers on
okay so that that's uh
two this is just uh
saying what i said already so in our
theorem the w2 tilde
is when i take the mixture the sum of
as i said this is asymmetric so we take
the
in each direction
yes i think so even
again as i said because
right but for on continuous imagine
continuous you have the square here
ah
but that assumes something about your
joint distribution yeah
okay one other thing is i i realized as
i was going through the slides uh
just before the talk um
if you just identify this quantity after
no before taking the info over pipe for
any given joint distribution pi
we
use
i2
now don't ask me why but
i2 of you might see a quantity in a
theorem later called i sub 2 and
t 2 is info over pi of i 2.
okay there's some remarks about maybe
i'll wait for a second about
you know you can ask okay what is this
distance if what is this
t2 the distance on the measured space if
you have a very simple distance zero one
right
right then it turns out it's not uh
it's not so strange
um
which is relevant for two point space so
so that
this slide is showing
one part of how we prove the result on
the discrete q as i said you prove we
prove something on the two point space
and then tensorize
but on two point space or any complete
graph
you
now that i introduced mu t pi
okay so you look at the relative entropy
of mu t pi with respect to mu mu is your
it could be counting or reference
measure
and just take the second derivative
okay this you can do explicitly
and usually you get that this is at
least that
so now you say okay that means this
minus t squared over 2 times w 2 tilde
square is convex
and so
plugging in at t equals 0 0 and 1
compared to arbitrarity gives you
inequality
basically
just checking for a convexity of
this function
okay
the proof of that is just following this
and a little bit more of algebra
so
and then as i said
you know the w2 tell that you can relate
to w1 so
notice that so if you haven't seen this
kind of things you might say okay well
how should i get any feel for it or what
is this good for
however trivial this seems we're on a
two-point space it gives something
interesting and useful that you might
have seen before namely the pinsker
inequality
right that says total variation square
is at most relative entropy
so for example take
um your reference measure mu to take mu
zero to be your reference measure mu
okay
mu zero if mu zero equals mu then
relative entropy of this guy is zero
okay
and
and this is non-negative so i'm going to
just throw this away relative
entertainment new t pi is this
non-negative
so what i get is that this term t
relative interval nu 1
is less than or equal to t times 1 so
cancel t and then
let t go to zero
so you will get that this is at least
okay even so even in this somewhat
trivial case you you get something that
you might have seen before
okay so this this is the
already mentioned how we go from two
point to uh in general
um
so
the perhaps
in terms of tensorization what might be
slightly different or new is it's not
the usual cancerization that you've seen
for product measures
this is something that the literature is
referred to as i guess independent works
of north and rosenblatt
introduced it
um but this this is somehow a very easy
thing to do you know even when you don't
have a product measure just write it
using conditional distributions right on
when you have on two points
um
and it's that one that works well for us
for the tensilization result
okay so uh let me be brief and
as
janmas indicated you know starting from
displacement convexity so he he
mentioned you can
derive modified log sub 11 equality and
then from that
you know concentration or
other things like decay of uh
mark of kernel to equilibrium and so on
um
so we you know we're not too pleased
with what we are able to do but
perhaps a small
uh
gratification is that in at the end we
are able to derive using the central
limit theorem
the usual log circular with the optimal
constant for the gaussian
so gross is the result
uh which
surprises a little bit because in the
middle you prove the modified locks over
not the usual logs of the level on the
screen
but
okay and then so this hwi goes back to
october any uh work uh
and so this diagram applies to every
graph or two
so every as yeah as with all diagrams if
you can establish this displacement
convexity of the type we i mentioned for
the description
then yeah under that hypothesis you can
prove this you can do that you can prove
a discrete break up alignment
so what is the
what is the largest generality it's for
any
metric spaces of some type of i mean so
okay visual spaces
good so
now i can say okay when can you when
does this diagram hold
okay
that's a great question because
um
right
so as i'm
i think going into negative minutes
pretty shortly let me uh let me address
that question
so
so far i hope i managed to convince you
that it could be interesting or could be
powerful to have such an inequality
okay and
one might even define if you can prove
such an inequality whatever the constant
is in front of the distance square you
might say maybe that's a lower bound on
your richie curvature for your graph
okay which for
the q would be constant over n
and this was the point of view taken by
olivia villani
okay
so it always feels that the balls are
closer than the center
also in negative curvature i mean either
uh it's probably not true
this is transportation right so this is
not
this is not
trivial
so okay i want to take quickly a couple
of things there is a course richie
introduced by you know
sort of almost uh
it was actually in my student's thesis
marcus samurai in 2005 last time we had
this
related special semester here i'm sorry
um
but i didn't encourage him to develop
this
so it's my fault but uh olivier actually
developed it quite well and again here
you can say maybe it's it should be
referred back to the brushing you know
this notion of richie curvature so what
is it and now the understanding is that
it's probably weaker than the than the
one suggested by displacement convexity
but this is fairly natural it's not
surprising for people in markov chains
here what this is saying is you take two
points a nearest point
and two the distance one take uh
take a random step from each one
and then compute w1 of where you are
if you're closer by some right if it's a
contraction
then you say that's a that's a local
richie and then
as usual you know the best lower bound
of this type is a lower bound on your
region
okay this is what olivia started with
that suggests for the cube
one over n
if you do that for symmetric with random
transpositions it suggests and choose
two
but all other in my chart modified log
several of spectral gap concentration
all these are of the order one over n
so this is why it would be very
interesting to figure out whether
displacement convexity for symmetric
group under hamming or transposition
distance holds
and
in particular if it holds with
one over n
that would show that this is in fact
coarse and weaker
okay
so
uh
put a conjecture here boldly
that it should be one over n um
okay this is
let me uh
all we are able to do as i said uh
is that
you have the following
just zero
zero curvature statement for the
symmetric group four t equals one half i
don't even have this for all t
and this uses uh gerum sinclair type
canonical path organ because you can
once you have this you try to form an
induction between i mean sorry an
injection
right from a cross b to
the midpoint set square
and you can do that by looking at
permutations
looking at the difference as cycles
which is natural and then try to fix
them in some canonical order
actually for the simple
case uh without curvature this is what
olivia will only do
they do a canonical argument
but then for the
to get the curvature down they need to
use a concentration inequality saying
that the midpoints are quite
representative and so on
and turns out for symmetric group one to
push that approach
results
throws us into proving concentration on
non-nested partition lattice
which is which is quite
seems quite non-trivial
so that's where we are and
uh so let me skip the proof of how we do
that canonical okay so
now if you if
if you dare to define that as your
notion of curvature of course it can be
negative
right for graphs let's say forget about
everything that we've seen in terms of
measures and say we do something like
this as a notion
you know
you pick a graph at random it's going to
have negative curvature
so it's not clear
how useful it is but there are
special graphs where they could have
positive curvature it could be very
useful but the negative curvature for
random graph is reasonable
yes the question next question might be
what can we do with it if i know this
statement for some lower bound and kappa
or negative
what can i do right so what's the red
what what is it red
this is type setting the red is the last
statement in any each slide
unfortunately no no no but what is it
saying
okay
yeah so take
let's read that by taking with uh
okay let's read item two first just just
take a star graph
it's extreme because take any subs two
subsets a and b there's a unique
midpoint right so how can you ask for
any sort of lower bound
okay
i mean this shows richie which is
usually a local
notion of curvature is in fact accurate
even in the graphs because
locally you can manufacture a star in a
graph if you have girth 5 why girth 5
because that means for neighbors of this
vertex there is no other shorter path
they can go through this common point
but any other path has to involve
but that already
yeah so that's
yeah but i mean isn't it a futurist for
you if you're substantial
yes and uh but this just is just a
warning
that this if you define simply that this
could be negative of course we yeah as
what you're saying if a and b are
substantial are sufficiently far apart
but that may be
just the general definition would be
i mean they could be substantial but you
can have so here for example take
complete bipartite graph a and b are on
the same side n and n plus one all their
midpoints are on the other side
again your interval
random graph so going back to gale's
question question
you know
is negative curvature still useful
somehow and then find more examples of
positive curvature
yeah the random graphs will have because
you know they would have
say random d regular graph they would
have large curves
and i would think in any decent expander
yes
the midpoints there is there are no
bottlenecks right so how can the the
mid-set
be small
so i mean is this a
of interest if you had an inequality
like this let's say if a and b are omega
i think i think it it is i think it's
it's
it's because the nature of richie is
local
what you're saying is well let me
disregard
this law
yes
which
then it could still be
couldn't you actually manufacture even
sort of large sets because this is
a transport here right so you could take
a large
well a lot of you know neatly pair up
with big set a with a big set b but but
just going
or they have to have a local phenomenon
is that
that you can match up like k points to k
points but with not with the shortest
paths
so the point is here that
you are matching them up with the
shortest paths
and and you can with a longer pass you
can do that but not
right now
let me just understand so i'll make a
statement which may be complete nonsense
so if
if the graph is is a reasonable expander
yes in a and b are somewhat largest at
least size epsilon
said because if i arrange the that the
item
they could be well connected
but
their nearest path is such that
the midpoint set will separate
a and b so sure
so if you have an expander it will be
also this mid percent will also be
linear
so
you're getting quality of this title
no
no if you have an expander
you have an expander you have two
disjoint sets a and b i'm yeah i'm
saying something completely true
so so this set of midpoints will
separate
this is the point
if i still don't understand the context
okay so
we have been discussing we have been in
discussion phase by the way
you are measuring your midpoint yes you
shouldn't say
you don't like floor and ceiling
like that
yeah yeah but i'm i'm just asking for
less than what you're asking for and i
still have trouble
all right yeah
yeah
okay
i yeah you know
so i could go on
start with two sets a and b that are
huge but separated by by distance five
and now
add an extra vertex
artificially that is connected to all of
them
to all of a and all of b then this
vertex would be the unique midpoint with
this definition okay
this counter
which is
i finished already
laurent wants to ask but he's being
polite
so this holds them
in also
sorry this
holds in any dimension
no that i don't know
why can't you use
it
but so here you know
the the proof is quite fragile rounding
up and down
as i achieved it doesn't matter so much
but then when on z2 already maybe there
is a way but it's not
obvious
i mean
well so
from our from the statement on r2 i have
to find an appropriate rounding and we
take some proof here
to show that i can discretize it
and because you get points when you take
t times a point
in r2 3 times a point in
you know 2 1 minus t times another point
i get some real number
and i have to find
midpoints in r2 and map them to mid
points in z2 appropriately
and it doesn't doesn't work as smoothly
i
i don't know
but
this is this is two weeks old so
first we said we should find out maybe
it's known
that you say like we remove epsilon
fraction of the energy then the graph
would satisfy this
things like that have you looked at
those things
i'm a little pessimistic with the
existing definitions because it's
maybe add based on your pulse suggestion
at one point
add a few edges
it seems that we are interested in
equality for large sets a and b
like far apart
and in that case
counting the
the size of
the support or the entropy of the
of the optimal plan between a and b yeah
saying that this is uh
seems much
saying
absolutely because you have the extra
term right we're saying stronger than
the displacement convexity is stronger
than much stronger
but if we are interested in obtaining
brandon
you have a lot of
midpoints
it's much larger than the support of the
yeah yeah
i think so i think so
it seems i mean that's why it's not